Let's keep an eye out for a missing witness
We still need him to testify
Should be easier to spot
now that everything's back to normal
Come on
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Marvel released a couple of deleted scenes
from Wandavision that explain a couple major
plot holes in general storylines
that they kind of dropped during the finale
and never really answered in Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness, or even the later movies.
So we'll break it all down.
the reason why we got these deleted scenes
is because they're releasing the Wandavision Blu ray.
They're doing that for the Loki Blu ray.
Star Wars is doing the same thing
with The Mandalorian, too.
So we're giving away a couple of copies
because it is a holiday week.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the Quicksilver character in the MCU
going forward.
When they introduce a bunch more X-Men.
We'll see a bunch of the older
X-Men coming back in Deadpool three
and then again during Avengers Secret Wars.
Like they're already doing
some classic X-Men characters,
but I'm talking about like beyond Marvel Phase seven.
When they introduce
the new MCU versions of the characters.
but there are a couple of storylines
that they resolved with this.
Ralph Bohner Quicksilver deleted scene.
This alternate ending
is just one of the two deleted scenes that we got.
They'll follow up on both of them
during the Wandavision spinoff series
Agatha Darkhold Diaries Next year, Halloween 2024.
that's meant to be a spinoff of the Wandavision series,
but it's not like Wandavision season two
because they'll get into a bunch of different witch
chaos magic, just magic related stuff in general.
this Quicksilver deleted scene is important
for a couple reasons.
It explains what happened to him
at the end of the series.
Like he literally cuts
the ankle bracelet off in escaped federal custody.
They were in the process of arresting him
with the sword.
People like Tyler Hayward, he's also rumored
to be coming back at some point during the Agatha show.
But they didn't say what he be doing during that.
He might just be there for the sake of continuity,
like for a cameos in the beginning
to explain what happens to Agatha
when she breaks out of Scarlet Witches spell.
The series is going to take place in West. You though.
it's like the whole idea is that
when she was enchanted again by Scarlet
Witch back into her sitcom role,
she went back to living it.
Ralph bohners house, believing that she was his wife.
when reality when the series was actually going on.
She was not under Scarlet Witch spell
and she was my controlling
Ralph Bohner to think that he was quicksilver
with Quicksilver's powers.
So Scarlet Witch
just made that sitcom reality real for Agatha.
While the spell is active.
but the idea here
like as you can see, like he's kind of hobbling here.
He looks kind of normal.
He only has his quicksilver powers
when Agatha wasn't under Scarlet witches.
Spell That's also why his haircut is different
from what it was earlier during the finale episode.
like he looks completely different.
Even his personality seems kind of different.
so this scene, when he comes hobbling in
to cut off his ankle bracelet
and then tried to escape into the distance
is meant to be happening during the wandavision
ending right after the Monica Rambeau scene
where she says goodbye to Scarlet Witch
and she flies off with the Darkhold
to go to her cabin in the wilderness to read from it.
the other reason why this scene is important
and some of you probably picked up on this
if you watch the scene a couple of times
is it reveals that Ralph Bohner was the witness,
that Jimmy Woo was coming to Westview
to find at the very beginning
of the series.
if you didn't remember the whole reason
why he showed up at the
hex was because he lost contact with his witness
that he'd had in witness protection.
so many people ask the same question
after they reveal that they never actually followed up
on who his mystery witness was like, who was the person
that he was they're looking for in the first place.
Turns out it was Ralph Bohner.
in, from the look of it here in this scene,
it's not totally clear if Ralph Bohner knows
that Jimmy Woo is the agent that he'd been working
with this whole time before Scarlet,
which created the hex, and Agatha took over his mind,
turning him into Quicksilver,
or if he did know that Jimmy was there looking for him
and just didn't want to have anything to do with him
or the federal agents and was just trying to
escape their custody, it just vanished into the wind.
Like white vision, who is also still M.I.A.
supposedly they're still doing that white Vision
series, The Vision Quest series,
but I haven't heard anything about it recently.
there are a bunch of other deleted scenes
with his version of Quicksilver that took place
before this during the big final battle
so one of the biggest things that they had to get
rid of in the storyline was a big subplot with Evan
Peters, Ralph character, Monica Rambeau,
the Darkhold senior Scratchy
in the Twins and Darcy's character
So what was going to happen is that Evan
Peters character, Ralph Bohner, was going to catch
Monica Rambeau
snooping on their house, snoopers going to snoop.
but while they were there, once Monica Rambeau
freed him of Agatha Harkness, his influence.
He was actually going to turn good and try to help them
stop Agatha Harkness and take the Darkhold.
So was Scarlet Witch and Agatha Harkness are having
their battle, their back and forth during the finale.
You have all this separate stuff happening with Ralph,
Monica, Rambeau Darcy in the Twins character
trying to steal the Darkhold from Agatha Harkness
basement technically was Ralph's basement,
What was going to happen, though, is that Senor
Scratchy was going to be guarding it
for Agatha Harkness.
so in the last couple of episodes that we saw him,
you just see Agatha
Harkness stroking him like,
clearly there's going to be some sort of reveal.
Like we find out that she was Agatha Harkness,
but they haven't fully revealed
what was going on with the bunny this whole time
so well, Monica Rambeau is busy freeing Ralph.
You have the twins moving in to help
because Billie and Tommy want to do something too.
they wind up going to Agatha Harkness, this house.
And then as they go down into the basement,
down into her lair that she had enchanted
with all those ruins, Senor Scratchy
was going to turn into a giant demon and literally
try to scratch them like that was what the name was.
All about, like a funny reference about him
having giant claws a lot of people heard this
and they're like,
does that mean that he was going to turn into
Mephisto or some larger,
more important Marvel comic book demon?
no, he was just going to turn into a general demon
that was being controlled by Agatha Harkness.
So you have this big fight scene with Monica Rambeau
Ralph in the background, cowering in fear,
and then the twins using their powers
as well, trying to stop Senor Scratchy
while they try to get their hands on the Darkhold.
Now, obviously, Agatha Harkness
still winds up getting the darkhold during the finale.
So eventually they would have been unsuccessful,
but it would have been a much bigger Marvel movie style
action scene where you see Monica Rambo
using her powers in a bigger way,
the twins using their powers in a bigger way,
and you would have had a bigger payoff
for the Ralph character because obviously we all wonder
what happens to Ralph after the end of the series.
Like Evan Peters character just goes back
to his normal life because she enchants Agatha Harkness
back into that identity of the nosy neighbor
in presumably she's going to move back into his house.
So the whole idea is that after that fight is done,
they wind out capturing him, putting him into custody.
And this is when he's escaping, like this
is when this deleted scene picks up.
if he really does wind up showing up at the beginning
of the Agatha show, what they'll probably say is that
Agatha breaks free of scarlet witches spell once
her essence transfers into the witch's road dimension,
which is meant to be like a separate dimension inside
the MCU multiverse.
is based on the witches road dimension from the comics.
Only witches are able to enter it using their power.
but basically the idea at the end of Doctor
strange multiverse of madness when she sacrifices
herself, her chaos magic
like her body acts to automatically protected
so it transforms her essence
using her chaos magic to this witch's road dimension.
it's a little bit like the way that life and death work
during the Moon Night series,
like they kind of explain that in the MCU,
how your consciousness transfers
to other dimensions,
this basically what happened to Scarlet Witch.
she's not supposed to be back in the physical MCU
Main universe till Avengers five,
but they'll reference her during the Agatha show
because her now adult son
Billy Kaplan a.k.a weakened is back in the MCU
being played by Joe Wallach.
It will be one of the characters
who helps her return to the main dimension.
That's not meant to happen for a while, though.
He's going to be doing young Avengers related stuff
before that to Ms..
Marvel putting together a team in.
If you're still confused about how Ralph Bonas
Quicksilver Powers worked essentially, Agatha
used her magic to enchant him, giving him superspeed in
the Powers were similar to those of Quicksilver.
So the funny thing about that
some of you probably thought about this
is that in order to do that,
she'd have to have seen or met
the real version of Quicksilver,
or a real version of Quicksilver from the Multiverse.
When the series originally aired, the theory was that
he was meant to be a variant of the Evan
Peters Quicksilver from the X-Men universe,
which is also canon to the Deadpool movies.
but all the X-Men that are meant to be coming back
during that movie are meant to be
the classic Bryan Singer versions of the characters.
So I don't know if his first class version
of the Quicksilver character is going to come back
during Secret Wars. We'll see.
we'll probably get that first Deadpool
three trailer sometime early next year.
But if we get any teasers before that,
of course I'll do videos for it.
it is going to be crazy, as you would expect.
there was another wandavision alternate
ending deleted scene that they released with Agatha.
Let me know in the comments if you want me
to do a video for that to I'm working on my invincible.
Season two Episode four Video
that should post pretty soon.
And there was a brand new Justice
League Crisis on Infinite Earths movie trailer.
I'll do a video for that next.
Be sure to enable all to my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here to learn about the Loki Scarlet
Witch Post-Credits scene
Easter Eggs and click here for my Loki Season
3 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!